what is a Gambit in chess a Gambit is a
material sacrifice made early in the
game for strategic gains often one
player gives up a pawn in return for
gaining time or space or some other type
of Advantage the most famous Gambit is
the Queen's Gambit thank you Beth it
goes like this
[Music]
now black can actually take this Pawn
but if they do that white is actually
going to gain control of the center and
in particular this Square after playing
the pawn there both whites Bishops are
completely open and free to develop
aggressively now black can also play
gambits too but they're usually more
dangerous because black has the second
move for example black can meet this
move with this one and this turns whites
slower more positional opening into one
that is a Minefield of tactics but black
may never see that pawn again gambits
can be fairly Advanced openings so dip
your toe in slowly there's a fine line
between a Gambit and giving your
opponent material that you're never
gonna see again
don't cross it